à votre avis comment parle aujourd'hui
on our affaires du savoir-faire du staff
avec qualcomm avec le nouveau sauf deux
pôles comme le 8 165 5 j'ai le temps de
faire quelques grosses vagues et les
rouleaux direct là bas j'y vais je vous
parle de toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une pièce mourinho
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça là le jour est en train
de se lever sur hawaï c'est quand même
vachement place je suis venu pour quatre
jours quatre jours à hawaii quatre jours
ça peut faire court quatre jours pour
parler des nouveaux processeurs de poils
comme lust un dragon 865 le 765 et le 7
165 g c'était un voyage paris seattle
seattle ma oui c'est un mais franchement
c'est cool surtout pour arriver sur ce
spot comme ça regardez moi ça derrière
vous avez la plage là vous avez la
montagne c'est ce volcaniques
si on revient train d'essayer quelque
part au fond là bas c'est volcaniques
alors au programme aujourd'hui je vous
emmène à la course de presse on va
regarder un peu ce que sont ces nouveaux
processeurs qui vous permettent de faire
est d'essayer de dresser en gros le
portrait robot du smartphone le plus
haut de gamme de l'année 2020 climbing
vraiment magnifiques lots hypra soldes
on ira faire en tout et tout à l'heure
il ya le restaurant du petit dash qui
est là le complexe est juste d'un regard
des mots simples
c'est magnifique ils ont vraiment fait
un tout nouveau ça par contre c'est pas
très très beau ces grandes barres
d'immeubles qui dit hôtel à l'américaine
il forcément chambre à l'américaine je
vous faire visiter ma petite pierre
d'autel par petit ça allait voir le truc
vous avez deux lits et non tous qui
complètement dingue six grands miroirs
qui situent juste notre côté hop avec le
lit le bureau pour venir bosser parce
que forcément ben oui il faut bien venir
bosser l'ordinateur la vue sur la
terrasse est juste ou fille si grande
télé ici timon deuil mais le clou du
spectacle se situe là bas des jarrets
des mois le couloir ici on peut se faire
une petite pause si on veut son problème
il ya tout ce qu'il faut ça c'est cool
mais le clou du spectacle c'est ici la
salle de bain regardez moi ce truc salle
de bains est juste et dans l'eure ça
c'est vraiment très américain vous
pouvez venir à 15 si vous voulez vous et
vos potes levier les ténors la baignoire
est juste dingue je sais pas combien on
peut rentrer là dedans mais je peux vous
assurez vous pouvez mettre du monde et
puis surtout à côté vous avez la douche
pense que oui si vous voulez venir vous
le répète je ne sais pas combien de
temps vous avez la douche vous avez la
baignoire c'est hypra grand bon ici
petit côté toilettes je vous passe le
placard dans l'entrée qui est aussi
juste
énorme comme c'est l'hiver en france
matthieu arrivent en doudoune mais ici
on voit la pente ur un petit peu rapide
de l'actuelle maintenant parler au petit
déjeuner enfin touria l'événement
aujourd'hui je crois que ça va être
énorme
[Musique]
dung
ah les gars c'est bon c'est bien sol ans
de bonheur regarder un petit peu mais
regardez cette truc je sais pas comment
vous le dire mais je sais même pas
comment vous le dira d'ailleurs on a
beaucoup de chance mais on apprend
beaucoup de choses également et qu'on va
vous dire et je pense monsieur grave je
me fais une belle tirade du matin la
tirade du matin réveil sera que plus
qu'on est content de la voix de claire
vous entendez le connaître le décalage
horaire connaît pas les onze heures de
décalage horaire je ne les vois pas je
vais très très bien peut-être la rue
vous pouvez pas savoir très bien ce
petit masque comme ça sur visage et
monsieur grue va vous faire un truc
génial comme il sait faire des toits qui
a fait des trucs jamais un montage qu'il
est capable de faire en 2 heures et moi
j'aimais de 20h10 à la défense ou lui
moi c'est une bille voit pas les bonnes
nuits c'est moi je croyais que mes
cheveux monsieur ho [ __ ]
[Musique]
on a fait les comptes de presse est
contre eux presse qui vous emmène sur la
plage à hawaï
ça j'en ai pas fait des masses donc bon
cet après midi petite visite à la place
piscine
[Musique]
mais ce matin conférence de presse où il
ya crise annuellement que le boss le big
boss de qualcomm qui va nous présenter
donc les nouveaux spas dragonne 865 765
765 gg pour gaming donc plus de
performances au niveau du de milieu de
gamme des forces on y fera couler qui
descend vraiment le portrait robot de ce
que met le smartphone plus haut de gamme
en tout cas au niveau de cette année
alors il n'y a pas que qualcomm
il ya aussi d'autres concurrents vous
avez alors du côté de silicone pour les
wê va ya voir apple qui a ses propres
puces
il ya aussi les exils aux de chez
samsung il n'y a pas que toi comme moi
quand tu vois quoi comme c'est un des
plus gros fabricants nous permettent de
voir ce qu'il va y avoir de plus
performants paraît vraiment déchaîné ce
fameux portrait robot des smartphones de
l'année 2020 je le garde parce que
qu'est-ce que de me faire mouiller les
pieds
en tout cas c'est cool on est donc parti
pour une grande journée à parler de teck
appareils smartphones la femme de
processeurs à pareille performance
ça c'est irak ou dans un spot qui est
juste incroyable
[Musique]
avec une prof qui a commencé là regardez
il ya tout le monde ça se remplit il ya
la scène les normes 5 juste derrière
pour annoncer l'équipe en haleine vous
s'adresse à vous savez jannik hastrup
c'est plutôt cool script très drôle ici
c'est que en fait des caisses toutes les
portes tout le monde petit cours qui se
jettent dessus on se croirait en jour du
sol comme ils ont sans doute bien croyez
c'est un peu n'importe quoi
vous avez la scène si vous regardez son
corrélat légèrement voyez vous avez le
prompteur qui est planqueel juste là
pour bien connaître les textes
en fond de salle il ya des moniteurs qui
sont aussi là regardez là
[Musique]
ces noeuds
on va se parler des différents points
performance photo/vidéo pas mal de
choses à dire là dessus en terme
d'autonomie mais aussi un gros gap qui
est vraiment intéressant vraiment fait
un focus sur le dernier sac le 865 5g et
on va parler un petit peu après du 765
et 1765 g vous allez voir franchement
c'est hyper intéressant non j'allais y
arriver les gars vous voilà je voulais
pas faire du bruit sur la grêle pirates
cécé loua de morgen les mecs qui sont
perdus savent pas où il faut aller d'une
façon globale ce qu'on va voir avec le
stade ragon 865 c'est un soft qui va
être plus performant permettra d'aller
plus vite la richesse beaucoup plus
rapidement être beaucoup moins
énergivore consommer beaucoup moins de
batterie d'avoir l'autonomie qui va
durer beaucoup plus longtemps d'avoir
des photos qui sont qualité vraiment
meilleur des vidéos qui seront beaucoup
meilleurs ont également un smartphone
qui chauffera moins par rapport à ce que
vous pourriez avoir avec des soc de la
génération d'avant
or aucune chose qui va mieux marché
beaucoup plus performant encore plus
autonome on s'attend d'ailleurs tout cas
dans le bon sens
moi je vous passe le côté un peu
technique vous avez un cri aux 585 qui
cadencé jusqu'à 2.84 gigahertz qui en
gros va être 25% plus performant que ce
que vous avez bien que la génération
précédente avec le qualcomm snapdragon 1
855 côté graphique vous avez une adreno
650 qui elle même 25 % plus rapide et
35% plus performantes
vous avez la cinquième génération du
moteur d'intelligence artificielle qui
apportera deux fois plus de performances
que la génération précédente et vous
allez pouvoir avoir de la mémoire lpddr2
5 mais également la mémoire lpddr2 4
voilà c'est pourtant un peu technique se
passe très rapidement là dessus on va
maintenant parler des usages
je vais commencer par vous parler de la
photo effectivement ils ont fait un
focus en disant qu'aujourd'hui on va
aller sur des smartphones avec cinq
capteurs photo comme ce qu'on a vu sur
le mint dc a pas très longtemps la
presse du show mythe vous en ai déjà
parlé si vous connaissez pas je vis avec
ma vidéo qui vous parlera d'une minute
dix comme ça vous saurez tout sur ce
smartphone avec cinq capteurs et c'est
là qu'on va aller au niveau de la
photographie l'année prochaine des
smartphones avec toujours plus de
capteurs qui permettront de passer d'un
objectif principal à un téléobjectif un
ultra grand angle à de la macro et un
capteur qui me servira pour le mode
portrait pour les faits évoqués
peut-être même pourquoi pas avec un
laser nous ont fait en tout cas
s'intéresse au niveau de la photo c'est
à dire qu'au lieu d'avoir un pixel
or ce très techniques en vue pour avoir
un pixel par cycle d'horloge ils en ont
calé 4 ça nous permet d'avoir plus
d'information il monte sur des photos
jusqu'en 200 mégapixels alors vous me
direz le pixel par pixel ça sert à quoi
en gros
si vous d'avoir plus de pixels c'est
tout simplement de voir venir croquer
dans l'image doit venir zoomer pendant
que vous prenez une photo de concert
vous voulez venir faire un zoom sur la
personne qui chante sur guitariste le
batteur ce que vous voulez le dj ou
compagnie bien vous pouvez le faire pour
dire krupp et sans perte de qualité
en tout cas ça y est d'avoir plus de
pixels du recadrage c'est intéressant
permettra aux caméras traiter jusqu'à 2
gigas pixels par seconde dont vous
traitez beaucoup plus d'informations par
seconde et d'être 40% plus rapide par
rapport au traitement d'image par
rapport à ce qu'on avait sur la
génération précédente vous pour aller
plus loin que ce soit en termes
d'honnêteté avec un autofocus qui sera
bien évidemment améliorer ou sur des
capacités de calcul qui sont vraiment
accru des photos de meilleure qualité
meilleur contraste la saturation mais en
était un autre n ont pas dû purement
global une expérience en termes de
photos qui sera vraiment améliorée qui
est intéressante et vous pouvez en même
temps filmé en cas de cas et si vous
souhaitez déclenchée et prendre une
photo en 64 mégapixels or l'idée de
prendre une photo de ce conflit mais
pouvait faire et vous n'arriviez pas sur
une qualité 64 mégapixels là vous pouvez
le faire parce que des capacités de
calcul qui a cru arrière et même au
niveau de la photo vous avez 16%
d'économies d'énergie en plus et c'est
intéressant parce que si vous montez
avec le san ramon 845 vous pouviez filmé
en 4k hdr 10 avec le 855 vous pouvez
filmer en 4k hdr 10 plus est avec le 865
vous pouvez filmer en dolby vision vous
êtes d'autres divisions qui débarque si
vous êtes un amateur de vidéos si vous
voulez film mais s'ils voulaient
vraiment augmenter votre qualité vidéo
vous pouvez le faire avec ce soc ça
c'est vraiment cool meilleur contraste
luminosité n'est peut-être pas tout cas
ça va dans le bon sens ça c'est vraiment
intéressant a tendrement thaï parti
c'est partout pareil
bon alors on va commencer l'été bochum
avec un truc qui m'a fait kiffer pendant
les démonstrations avec l' annonce
lié à dolby hausse avec rome un fan à la
vague dolby depuis que j'ai 12 ans et
demi à peu près d'olbia clause de
division et l'ajustement de division
pour la première fois la première fois
au monde romain non
mais en 4k jusqu'à 120 images par
seconde mais quelque chose d'ultra
fluide hyper smoothies noter que vous
allez pouvoir avoir du slow motion sans
aucune limite de temps jusqu'à 900 60
images par secondes et vous allez même
pouvoir filmer jusqu'en 8 k filmé en 8k
alors aujourd'hui ça n'a strictement
aucun intérêt films ont eu qu'à parce
que vos écrans de toute façon vous êtes
sur du full hd plus haut niveau des
smartphones donc avoir la définition
huit cas ça très peu d'intérêt en tout
cas ce qui est intéressant d'un point de
vue marketing pour qualcomm c'est que ça
montre la force avant que la puissance
avant que la performance que vous avez
au niveau de ce socle il ya un autre
point d'autres usages qui est vachement
important au niveau des smartphones
c'est la partie gainey le secteur du
gaming explose
et comme on a beaucoup de performances
pour le gaming ça va être juste énorme
il ya des trucs qui est intéressant
c'est que vous avez pour mettre votre
gpu dans toute la partie graphique à
jour via le ps store comptait 12 ans
toujours la meilleure expérience au
niveau graphique vous aurez toujours ce
qui se fait de mieux
du point de vue purement logicielle
toute cette performance permettra
lorsque vous allez jouer de pouvoir
monter jusqu'en 144 r si je pense que
c'est là dessus qu'on va arriver sur les
smartphones de gaming je parle
effectivement de sens d'ailleurs mais je
pense que le 144 hertz a un sens en tout
cas je le dis pour des marques comme
razer pour des marques comme asus
androphone de vouloir monter avec des
écrans extrêmement fluide toujours plus
de performances que derrière vous avez
les capacités calcul et il ya tout un
travail qui a été fait sur un parti qui
s'appelle game color plus qui permet
d'améliorer pas son nom en général la
colorimétrie l'image le détail la
saturation toutes les parties avec des
jeux dont des jeux de lumières seront
vraiment complètement améliorées dont
plus de détails meilleure qualité
lorsque vous allez jouer à vos jeux donc
ça s'est vraiment bien et tu fais partie
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est tout
ce qui correspond à la connectivité
notamment internet alors vous avez un
modem 5 g c'est toute la 5g vous avez le
modèle x 55 de deuxième génération alors
une fois de plus je vous passe un petit
peu le côté très technique et nous
annonce que vous pouvez monter jusqu'à
7,5 gigabit en téléchargement maximale
ça paraît relativement énorme il faut
déjà que vous aviez la 5g chez vous
alors le truc qui est un petit peu what
the fuck avec le 865 c'est que il est 5
g si vous achetez un smartphone qu'il ya
le 8 165 d'un smartphone 5 g alors
rassurez-vous s'il tourne sur la singer
il tournera sur la quête j'ai bien
évidemment mais vous acheter un
smartphone qui est prêt pour la 5g alors
effectivement là cinq gènes pas encore
arides en france par qu'en france parce
qu'il ya d'autres pays dans lequel elle
publie notamment en suisse mais pour la
france c'est pas le cas si vous achetez
un smartphone équipé avec ce soc dès
l'année prochaine dès 2020 parce qu'un
disponible l'année prochaine
vous savez votre rôle sera déjà prêt
pour la 5g dont vous êtes tranquille
pour lire
et deux trois quatre années à venir sans
aucun problème donc la touche d vraiment
tranquille parce que si vous pensez
vraiment à renouer le smartphone et
n'achetez pas ce matin avec un modem 5 j
à l'intérieur et bien lorsque vous
voudrez passé à la 5g
il va falloir changer votre matériel bon
en tout cas ça c'est plutôt bien le
savoir il est certifié wifi 6 bluetooth
5.1 qui me permettra notamment
d'appareiller par exemple et bien deux
écouteurs sur le même smartphone vous
êtes-vous compagne compagnon qui vous
voulez eh bien vous avez vous écouteurs
l'autre à ces écouteurs vous regarde un
film ensemble bien vous pouvez tous les
deux avoir vos écouteurs indépendamment
il ya un gros faux plus qu'à taper sur
la sécurité là dessus donc de ce point
de vue là on est peinard il ya aussi un
gros focus qui est fait au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle alors mon
jeu nous nous utilisent tous des
artificiers sans forcément le savoir ne
serait-ce qu'au niveau des photos pas
mal de choses google lance par exemple
vous avez là est déjà sortie officielle
mais la gratuité vachement intéressante
à dire que vous pourriez par exemple
parler à quelqu'un au téléphone en
français en anglais ce que vous voulez
votre interlocuteur en face et chinois
parlent chinois ne parle ni anglais ni
français vous voulu parler en français
ça va comprendre ça va traduire
automatiquement lui va entendre
directement en chinois il va vous
répondre aux chinois et voulant trop en
france et alors j'ai pas testé ce
système ça peut le faire en tout cas
d'un point de vue purement capacités de
calcul a testé mais en tout cas ça
promet des joutes sont vraiment ils
prêts intéressants alors l'intelligence
artificielle est là pour apporter de
nouvelles fonctionnalités mais aussi
pour améliorer significativement les
performances de vos smartphones et
notamment au niveau de l'autonomie donc
là on aura aussi une autonomie qui sera
aussi bien meilleurs et notamment grâce
à l'intelligence artificielle on nous
rend google has histoire par exemple il
sera trois fois moins énergivore 30% de
latence en moins est à noter que le
premier smartphone à équiper cette puce
le cendre est dans une bulle 165 et bien
ça sera le chien aux mines midi ce qui
va sortir début 2010 maintenant du côté
de justin braun 765 et 7 165 g il a
rendu plus sûr du milieu de gamme on va
les moins au niveau de la performance on
va au niveau de la 5g et de
l'intelligence artificielle avec la
cinquième génération de qualcomm
hays engine je savais tout noter là j'ai
pas tout appris par coeur un record au
niveau de la photo vous allez pouvoir
les unes plus loin les poires filmé en
4k hdr vous allez avoir du super slow
motion jusqu'à 480 images par secondes
toute la partie aussi qualcomm élite
gaming plus rapide plus performants
moins énergivore attache équivalent par
rapport à ce que vous avez à une
dernière un smartphone qui va moins
chauffer car des gens profitent vous
faire respirer l'endroit regardez-moi
salles aujourd'hui le temps est pas ouf
mais si justin
blanc du bien on se met à l'aise à
l'abri directement hawaï là-bas la plage
regardez moi c'est comme c'est
magnifique
le spot est juste ou flat on a envie
d'aller se baigner là lance un petit peu
agitée regardez masala les baraques
vous en avez qui se met bien là avec la
vue directement la sas et c'est
justement alors tout ça c'est bien beau
mais qu'est ce que ça nous montre alors
ça nous montre qu'on va aller
effectivement vers des smartphones
beaucoup plus rapide je pense que là on
s'en serait douté donc beaucoup plus de
rapidité toujours plus d'intelligence
artificielle derrière pour vous
accompagner tous les jours de votre vie
quelque chose qui va être moins
énergivores qui apportera de nouvelles
fonctionnalités alors c'est assez
intéressant mais va falloir voir de
quelle manière et constructeurs vont
prendre ça en main qu'est-ce qu'on part
développé comment ils vont pouvoir
l'utiliser pour apporter une nouvelle
fonctionnalité directement au niveau des
smartphones que ça on le verra pas ce
que d'un constructeur à l'autre et bien
il faut pas utiliser de différentes
manières ailleurs plein de choses à
faire dans ce cas ça montre clairement
la ligne droite la ligne droite c'est le
gaming la ligne droite c'est la photo la
vidéo c'est bien évidemment l'expérience
améliorable plus de fidélité une
meilleure autonomie et ce patrouilleur
2020 qui vont être beaucoup plus rapide
beaucoup moins énergivores qui vont
faire un gros focus sur le
divertissement sur la photo on va
continuer ce qu'on faisait en 2019 on va
le faire ont beaucoup nui aux dites moi
ce que vous en pensez vous qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
l'idée d'avoir de la guica est ce que
vous pourriez vous utilisez la nuit
casque c'est un sens pour vous d'aller
filmer en 8k moi je pense que très
clairement c'est montre la force nous
sont capables de faire il montre un
petit peu le la force de frappe de
qualcomm là dessus la grille car on n'y
est pas encore on n'a pas des écrans
lucas comme je vous le disais on n'est
pas encore prêt mais pourquoi pas en
tout cas ça c'est sexy ça peut être
intéressant à voir ça donnera sur des
moniteurs moi je la cerec sur mon
macbook pro ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir film est effectivement avec du
dolby vision en 4k voir si effectivement
le smartphone pour un côté un peu
veloppe peut être meilleur en termes de
qualité passe quand tout ce qui est
photo c'est pas mal autant souvent ski
et vidéo au niveau des smartphones c'est
un petit peu difficile ça dépend des
smartphones alors une fois de plus on va
être les smartphones haut de gamme barre
très haut de gamme avec ce socle à avec
le cendre agonie 865 avoir à voir mais
en tout cas je trouve ça cool beaucoup
de performances et moi ce que vous en
pensez vous en bas en commentaire
comment vous la voyez vous la dès 2020
au niveau des smartphones
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour la 5g
est ce que vous voyez les usages de la
famille parce que ça je voulais pas dit
mais c'est aussi un des usages important
avec ce socle à la 5g arrive elle arrive
un peu partout et commence à déployer en
france ça sera pas avant
me 2020 pour qu'on retrouve un peu
partout je dirais à partir de 2021 2022
mais ça commence ça arrive donc c'est
plutôt cool moi ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire maintenant on se
retrouve dès demain pour continuer par
l'état qui s'embrassent ciao
[Musique]